der nächste Einzelplan Einzelplan 10
Landwirtschaft
wird jetzt als nächstes diskutiert
7,18 Milliarden Euro sind vorgesehen im
nächsten Jahr so viel soll
Bundesminister Jim Özdemir ausgeben
können besonders die Zuschüsse zur
Alterssicherung der Landwirte spielen da
eine große Rolle sowie auch die
Zuschüsse zur Krankenversicherung der
Landwirte aber natürlich geht es hier
auch um die Politik also wie auch hier
die Landwirtschaft nach vorne gebracht
werden kann Themen sind dann natürlich
auch die Tierwohl Abgabe das ist auch
eine Debatte die ja schon seit Jahren
hier im Parlament ist wie die gestaltet
werden soll wie freiwillig unfreiwillig
da die Produzenten sich dazu bekennen
sollen
genaueres können wir jetzt vom
Bundesminister für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft Tim Özdemir hören
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
mein Haus und ich arbeiten tagtäglich
für eine zukunftsfähige Landwirtschaft
ohne und das will ich ausdrücklich sagen
dabei auch die Leistungen der
Vergangenheit zu schmälern mit diesem
Haushalt fördern wir den notwendigen
Wandel zu einer Landwirtschaft die
resilienter wird gegenüber Krisen die
Klima und Artenvielfalt schützt und die
unsere Lebensgrundlagen bewahrt damit
wir auch morgen noch zur Sicherung
unsere Nahrung beitragen können wir
investieren in Forschung wir investieren
in Entwicklung damit unsere
Forschungslandschaft innovativ ist und
es auch in Zukunft bleibt die
agrarsoziale Sicherung ist widerstabiler
Kosten wir stärken den ökologischen
Landbau um neue Impulse für einen
nachhaltige Landwirtschaft zu setzen wir
bringen uns wir bringen die dringend
notwendige Digitalisierung voran wir
fördern nachwachsende Rohstoffe und
stärken damit auch ländliche Räume
und sicher nicht zuletzt wir stellen den
Wandel hin zu einer zukunftsfesten
Tierhaltung in den Mittelpunkt unserer
Arbeit denn auch in den Stellen auf den
Weiden und an der Ladentheke entscheidet
sich die Zukunft von uns allen gerade
was die Tierhaltung angeht wird die
Geduld der Landwirte nun Landwirte schon
zu seit zu vielen Jahren strapaziert es
ist überfällig dass der Wandel der
Tierhaltung zum Wohle der Tiere der
Bäuerinnen und Bauern des Klimas unter
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher endlich
aufs Gleis gesetzt wird mit 100 mit 150
mit 150 Millionen starten wir in diesem
Haushalt den Weg in eine zukunftsfeste
Tierhaltung in den kommenden Jahren
werden wir die Summe weiter steigern
jetzt ist die Politik gefragt den Umbau
der Stelle zu fördern und ich
unterstreiche es auch bei laufenden
Kosten zu unterstützen bis der Wandel
sich schließlich selbst tragen kann die
Bäuerinnen und Bauern die auf eine
tierfreundliche Haltungsform umsteigen
wollen brauchen Planungssicherheit das
entscheidet auch darüber ob unser
Fleisch weiterhin aus Deutschland kommt
oder ob es künftig aus dem Ausland kommt
ich möchte
und das klar zu sagen ich möchte als
bundeslandwirtschaft eine Minister das
ist aus Deutschland kommt das ist gutes
Fleisch ist von gut gehaltenen Tieren
und übrigens auch unser Getreide und
unsere Gemüse braucht Tierhaltung es
braucht Gülle und mischt als Dünger ich
bin optimistisch dass wir bei der
Tierhaltung auch im Sinne unsere
Landwirte Landwirte zu einer guten
Lösung kommen sie geschätzte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen entscheiden mit diesem
Haushalt auch über die Zukunft unserer
Tierhaltung in unserem Land ich hoffe
natürlich dass sie dabei ich will das
nochmals sagen auch die Bezuschussung
der laufenden Betriebskosten für mehr
Tierwohl unterstützen damit wir da
endlich
ein Knopf dran machen können
der Schutz des Klimas und die Zukunft
unserer Landwirtschaft entscheidet sich
auch in unseren Wäldern im Jahr auch in
unseren [ __ ] dort muss die Anpassung
an die Folgen der erderhitzungen die
Bekämpfung der Klimakrise gleichermaßen
stattfinden wir brauchen den biologisch
vielfältigen und den fitten Wald als
klimaschütze deshalb investieren wir in
den kommenden Jahren insgesamt 900
Millionen Euro in die Klima- und
biodiversitätsfreundliche
Bewirtschaftung damit
damit unterstützen wir diejenigen die
sie um unsere Wälder kümmern und von
ihnen leben
wir investieren zugleich in den Schutz
unserer Moore und die taufminderung ich
will das als eine Art Klimaanlage
bezeichnen wo wir da investieren ich
danke dem Umweltministerium an der
Spitze mit Steffi Lemke die in ihrem
Haushalt dazu auch wichtige Akzente
setzt ich danke insbesondere aber vor
allem unseren Landwirtinnen und
Landwirten namentlich dem landfolge
Niedersachsen die sich aktiv bei dem
Thema Moorschutz einbringen
es ist es ist keine
das ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit
denn Hand aufs Herz das ist mit
Zumutungen das ist mit Anstrengungen und
auch mit notwendigen Kompromissen
verbunden doch dort stellt man sich eben
darausforderungen duckt sich nicht weg
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Opposition
die Zukunftskommission Landwirtschaft
hat unschätzbare Arbeit geleistet
landwirtschaftliche Verbände auf der
einen Umweltverbände auf der anderen
Seite haben viel Kraft manchmal sogar
ihre ganze Reputation investiert um
endlich alte Gräben zu überwinden das
Abschlusspapier hat Hoffnung geweckt auf
eine konstruktive für eine gemeinsame
Zukunft wer jetzt wieder so tut als ob
Umwelt und Tierschutz nicht die
Grundlage sondern der Gegner der
Landwirtschaft sind der tritt dieser
Arbeit mit Füßen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und manche und manche der jetzt
behauptet etwas gegen den Welthunger
unternehmen zu wollen wird schlicht und
einfach die Abhängigkeit armer Länder
von Lebensmitteln Importen weiter gut
damit verdienen damit hilft man diesen
Ländern nicht wir werden nicht auf
diejenigen hereinfallen die die alten
Rezepte jetzt wieder hervorholen es
mutet schon bizarrern das will ich an
der Stelle schon mal sagen dass ein
grüner Agrarminister jetzt darüber
wachen muss das Zusagen aus der Zeit
seiner christdemokratischen
Vorgängerinnen und Vorgänger eingehalten
werden während in die cdu/csu genau
dafür kritisiert dass die Versprechen
die früher mal gegeben wurden als das
Haus schwarz geführt wurde eingehalten
werden ich finde das hat was mit
Planungssicherheit und
Investitionssicherheit zu
Verlässlichkeit
Kompromissbereitschaft Maß und Mitte des
galtenmaler als Tugenden auch in ihren
Reihen und es wäre schön wenn das wieder
so wird liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
werden wandel-landwirtschaft bremst ist
kein Freund der Bäuerinnen und Bauern in
unserem Land ganz im Gegenteil wir
müssen und wir werden unsere Landwirte
nun Landwirte bei diesem Wandel
unterstützen und genau deshalb habe ich
bei meinen Entscheidungen immer stets
versucht es notwendige und es Machbare
gleichermaßen im Blick zu behalten aber
es muss uns klar sein der Schutz von
Klima Böden Wasser und Artenvielfalt
entscheidet auch darüber ob wir morgen
noch unsere Nahrung sichern können in
der Landwirtschaft bei allem so
weiterzumachen kann keine Option sein
deshalb treiben wir mit diesem Haushalt
den Wandel zu einer zukunftsfesten
Landwirtschaft weiter voran herzlichen
Dank
Bundesminister für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft Cem Özdemir hat sich hier
auch direkt an die Union gewandt denn
auch die Union hat sich hier ja
vorher mit Kritik geäußert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Bundesminister ich mache mir
große Sorgen um die Zukunft der
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland denn sie
ist bei diesem
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister nicht in
guten Händen
bald ein Jahr nach der Bundestagswahl
zeigt sich die Politik die Minister
Özdemir durchsetzen will hat in Wahrheit
weder in ihrer Koalition noch in diesem
Haus eine Mehrheit und seit Amtsantritt
versuchen Sie Herr Minister Özdemir dies
mit gefälliger Rhetorik zu verschleiern
haben wir gerade auch so ein bisschen
erlebt aber jetzt mit den
fortschreitenden Folgen des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine gerade
auch auf den Bereich der ernährungs- und
Landwirtschaftspolitik gelingt ihnen
dies immer weniger in der Krise ist
dieser Minister als Anwalt der Landwirte
der Gärtner der Weinbauern der
Obstbauern der Bäcker als Anwalt der
Ernährungsbranche insgesamt leider ein
Totalausfall und das gilt auch für die
gesamte Bundesregierung
also mit Herrn Habeck und seinen
Ausführungen zum Bäckerei Gewerbe in
Zeiten der Energiekrise haben uns dieser
Tage schon ausführlich beschäftigt aber
schauen wir uns jetzt mal den Beschluss
des Koalitionsausschusses vom Sonntag an
auch da steht reichlich wenig drin was
unseren produzierenden Betrieben dem
Mittelstand insgesamt etwas Zuversicht
für die kommenden Herausforderung geben
könnte stand jetzt
stand jetzt müssen wir festhalten sie
tun nichts um das Sterben der
Traditionsbäckerei in der Dorfmitte zu
verhindern sie tun nichts um die
Betriebsaufgabe des familiengeführten
gärtnereibetriebs abzuwenden sie tun
nichts und wir verlassen den Bundestag
aufgrund der aktuellen Entwicklung in
Großbritannien an dieser Stelle und die
Kollegen in Bonn informieren Sie nun
über alles weitere Thomas Bade bitte
Glückwunsch zur guten Ortswahl haben sie
gesagt dass es Scharfmacher gäbe die die
globale Ernährungssicherung als Vorwand
nutzen würden dem Klima und Artenschutz
in der Landwirtschaft zurückzufahren mit
falschen Tatsachen Behauptungen und mit
falschen Versprechen wenn meinen sie
wenn sie von scharf machen sprechen die
FDP die Landwirtschaftsminister der
Länder sind Bauernverband und die
EU-Kommission also so ziemlich alle
anderen
die globale Ernährungssicherung ist eine
große Aufgabe der wir uns angesichts der
Folgen des Ukraine Kriegs zu stellen
haben und deshalb war es auch richtig
dass sie nachgegeben haben bei der Frage
der flächenstilligung nächsten Jahr 2023
sollten ja vier Prozent der Ackerflächen
stillgelegt werden das wird nun nicht
passieren und alles andere wäre auch
wirklich unverantwortlich gewesen
angesichts der Kriegsfolgen angesichts
der hunger-krisen die in vielen Regionen
der Welt jetzt schon Tatsache sind oder
in vielen weiteren Regionen drohen ihre
Entscheidung kam spät fast zu spät für
viele Betriebe aber gut dass sie noch
getroffen wurde
aber auch für die Zukunft stellt sich
die Frage kann es sein dass wir in
Deutschland und Europa immer weniger
Nahrungsmittel produzieren frei nach dem
Motto wir haben ja genügend Geld um uns
auf den Weltmärkten mit allem
einzudecken ist das
verantwortungsbewusst anderen Regionen
der Welt gegenüber
diese Debatte meine Damen und Herren
müssen wir führen und wir müssen auch
manche Bestandteile der europäischen
Agrarpolitik auf den Prüfstand diese
Debatte sollten Sie mitgestalten und
zwar im Sinne der Landwirtschaft anstatt
ihre Gesprächspartner die nicht auf der
grünen Linie sind zu diskreditieren
ich stelle ein paar aktuelle Beispiele
für Vorhaben auf europäische Ebene die
ihre Gründe haben aber vielleicht nicht
ganz zu Ende gedacht sind die Verordnung
zu Wiederherstellung der Natur diese
Verordnung würde massive
Produktionseinschränkungen für die Land
und Forstwirtschaft bedeuten Industrie
emissionsrichtlinie diese Richtlinie
würde zukünftig zehnmal so viele
tierhaltungsbetriebe in Deutschland
erfassen da drohen massive zusätzliche
Auflagen und ausrufernde Kosten und dann
die eu-pflanzenschutzverordnung da hat
ja niemand was dagegen wenn der Einsatz
von Pflanzenschutzmitteln reduziert wird
da wo es Sinn macht da wo es möglich ist
es gibt aber Gartenbaubetriebe es gibt
Weinbau und der existenzgefährdet ist
wenn pauschale und überzogene
Reduktionsziele in einem viel zu weit
gefassten Gebiet durchgesetzt werden
sollen das darf so nicht kommen meine
Damen und Herren
Aufforderung an Sie klären Sie diese
Fragen in der Koalition klären Sie diese
Fragen in der Bundesregierung aber
klären Sie auch das so zentrale Thema
Tierwohl und dessen Finanzierung da
haben wir gerade eben schöne Worte dazu
gehört
heute hat die borchert-kommission getagt
das ist gut dass die porsche-kommission
ihre Arbeit fortsetzen möchte sie sollte
allerdings aufrütteln dass die
Kommissionsmitglieder angekündigt haben
so lange zu pausieren bis die Koalition
endlich die Frage der Finanzierung des
Umbaus der Nutztierhaltung gelöst hat
wir alle Fragen uns wofür steht die
Koalition wir warten dringend auf ein
stimmiges Gesamtkonzept und da lässt
dieser Haushaltsentwurf erneut alles im
Unklaren klären sie endlich diese Frage
alle warten darauf geht an die gesamte
Koalition auch an die FDP
die traurige Zwischenbilanz ein Jahr
nach der Bundestagswahl lautet kein
frisches Geld für die Investitionen in
den stallumbau keine Finanzierung der
laufenden Kosten und ein Gesetzentwurf
zur tierhaltungskennzeichen und der viel
mehr Fragen offen ist als er antworten
gibt Herr Minister Özdemir für ihr
zukünftiges wirken will ich Ihnen zum
Schluss noch ein Thema ans Herz legen
des bislang bei ihnen eigentlich keine
Rolle spielt sie haben vorher das
Stichwort Innovation genannt aber auch
wenn man sich den Haushalt anschaut
spielt es viel zu wenig eine Rolle
Innovation neue Technologien nur wenn
Sie hier Ihre Scheuklappen ablegen dann
können Sie glaubhaft für eine
nachhaltige Landwirtschaft eintreten wir
brauchen neue robuste Pflanzen die
widerstandsfähiger sind gegen Hitze
gegen Dürre und es ist möglich Ernährung
zu sichern und gleichzeitig Umwelt und
Biodiversität zu schützen aber dafür
braucht es Mut auch mal neue Wege zu
gehen Mut den ich bislang bei ihnen
vermisse
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
gerade die Nachricht erhalten dass Queen
Elizabeth II im Alter von 96 Jahren
verstorben ist ich möchte Sie darüber
informieren
es gebührt sich glaube ich dass wir kurz
aufstehen die Präsidentin wird morgen
noch mal einleitende Worte dazu sagen
vielen Dank nehmen Sie bitte wieder
Platz
wie gesagt die Präsidentin wird morgen
noch mal einleitend sagen dazu wir sind
denke ich alle in Gedanken bei der
Familie
es fällt jetzt auch schwer an der
Debatte vorzuführen aber ich denke wir
werden das mit der nötigen Ruhe und auch
Angemessenheit im Ton weiter tun und die
nächste Rednerin ist ist ja SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in der Tat
nach dieser Nachricht ist es jetzt nicht
so ganz einfach zur Tagesordnung
überzugehen aber ich denke wir werden
uns morgen in aller Ruhe und mit dem
gegüten gebührenden Respekt dann noch
mal in Gedanken an das Staatsoberhaupt
in Großbritannien erinnern
7,1 Millionen stehen im Einzelplan 10
für landwirtschaftliche Sozialpolitik
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe agrar und
Küstenschutz diverse Forschungsinstitute
und zusätzlich bewirtschaftet das
Ministerium aus dem
klima-377,5 Millionen
zurzeit
beschäftigt mich ein Thema ganz
besonders
unsere Wälder brennen
Ende Juli diesen Jahres im Nationalpark
Sächsische Schweiz und zurzeit im Harz
am Brocken
vor wenigen Tagen hatte ich Gelegenheit
mit meinen Kollegen und Kolleginnen
Susanne Mittag Sylvia Lehmann Isabel
Macken sind Geist und Fabian Funke
Nationalparkzentrum in Bad Schandau zu
besichtigen
beeindrucken zunächst erstmal die
Feststellung in dem Imagefilm der dort
gezeigt wird ein Glücksfall im richtigen
Moment auf der Erde zu sein um diese
wunderbaren Naturlandschaften erleben zu
können
da wurden wunderschöne unberührte
Landschaften gezeigt beeindruckte
Aufnahmen vom Schwarzstorch von der
Wasseramsel vom Wanderfalken und mit
einer kurzen Geschichte wie beginnen vor
90 Millionen Jahren aus Sandkörnern die
heutigen Felsformationen mit den Tälern
und Schluchten entstanden sind
danach sind wir rauf gefahren zu den
brandflächen
dort haben wir auf die
Zerstörung ja wortlos geguckt die uns
dann rechts und links des schmalen Weges
begleitet hat gefällte Fichten um die
Verkehrssicherheit auf dem Weg zu
gewährleisten buchen mit braunen
Blättern wie im Herbst und dann die
verkohlten schwarz-grauen Baumstämme
teils liegen kreuz und quer teils noch
stehend soweit das Auge reicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich kann nur
sagen
Hochachtung und danke für den
erfolgreichen und logistisch sehr
anspruchsvollen Einsatz an alle
Nationalpark Mitarbeiter an die
Forstverwaltung an die Feuerwehr an den
Katastrophenschutz an private
Flugunternehmen an die Polizei THW
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern die mit allen
Mitteln und all ihren Kräften tagelang
gegen diese Brände gekämpft haben
zukünftig liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
werden wir auch dies hier als weitere
Herausforderung annehmen müssen für
staatskommunalen Privatwald wenn wir
Unterstützung anbieten zum Beispiel für
die Honorierung zur
ökosystemenleistung Wald wofür ja 200
Millionen Euro im
transformationsfonds zur Verfügung
stehen eine zusätzliche Herausforderung
die wir berücksichtigen müssen sehr
geehrter Herr Minister mit dem
Präsidenten des hessischen
waldbesitzerverbandes Karl-Anton zu
Waldeck und dem geschäftsführenden
Direktor Christian Raupach sowie
einzelnen Waldbesitzern und
Wissenschaftlern stehe ich im regen
Austausch schon seit langer Zeit war
mich das Thema einfach interessiert ich
komme aus einer Gegend in der es viel
Wald gibt
und die ist sehr begrüßen würden wenn
sie mich zu einem der nächsten Termine
vor Ort auch einmal begleiten würden
sehr geehrter Herr Minister meine
Kollegen Sebastian Schäfer dem ich von
hier aus sehr sehr herzliche
Genesungswünsche sende
daher heute an der Debatte nicht
krankheitsbedingt nicht teilnehmen kann
und Frank Scheffler haben sich
sicherlich genauso wie ich gefreut dass
Sie unsere parlamentarische Initiative
in den Beratungen und der
Bereinigungssitzung zum Haushalt 2022 zu
schätzen wissen nachdem es Ihnen leider
wahrscheinlich wegen des Finanzministers
nicht gelungen war bestimmte Vorhaben im
letzten Regierungsentwurf zu platzieren
aber danke für Ihre presseunterstützung
zur Unterstützung der Tierheime die
ukrainische Tiere versorgen mussten für
die haben wir fünf Millionen zur
Verfügung gestellt und mit Verlaub ich
habe es mitgebracht dass Katzenfoto mit
kv-kater Udo war echt Hit verdächtig
danke auch für ihr Bekenntnis in der
Zeit
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister will mehr
Rehkitze vor metod schützen durch
Einsatz von Drohnen
ebenfalls in der Zeit haben Sie unseren
Einsatz für die küstenschiffe gewürdigt
für die wir als Haushälter in ihrem
Einzelplan 10 Millionen Euro zur
Verfügung gestellt haben und diese
Betriebsbeihilfen sind auch zügig bei
den Fischern angekommen danke auch dafür
ebenso haben sie nach meinen
Informationen ich habe ja da sehr viele
Fragen gestellt ist mir aus dem
Ministerium berichtet worden was wohl
ein bisschen Arbeit verursacht hat das
Geld für den neuen für unseren neuen
Titel den wir schaffen wollten Förderung
von Pilotprojekten zur Schaffung
regionaler Produktions- und
Verwertungsketten für Produkte aus
Aquakulturen auch bereits ausgegeben ich
frage mich nur warum stehen diese
wichtigen und durchaus leicht aus dem
Haushalt des bmel teilt sogar aus
bestehenden Titeln zu finanzierenden
Projekte im Regierungsentwurf für 2023
schon wieder nicht drin der Vermerk für
die rehkitzrettung gestrichen die
Seefischer nicht berücksichtigt der
Vermerk dass wir den neuen Titel
Projekte Aquakulturen schaffen wollten
völlig weggefallen und auch kein neuer
Titel und zweitens warum liegen die
Förderungen bzw die Richtlinie für die
Förderung der Tierheime bis heute nicht
vor ich glaube die kommen nicht so oder
übernächste Woche wenn ich das richtig
im Auge habe
obwohl hier ja die Vorlage aus dem BMU
hätte genutzt werden können in dem
haushaltswallen im letzten Haushalt
nämlich diese Beihilfen eingestellt ich
bin aber zuversichtlich Herr Minister
dass wir diese Dinge in den laufenden
Hals Haushaltsberatungen auch wieder
klären werden und an dieser Stelle mein
ausgesprochener Dank an ihre
parlamentarische Sitz des
Staatssekretärin Manuela Rottmann und an
ihre Mitarbeitenden im Haus die
versuchen zeitnah alle Fragen der
Berichterstatter und Berichterstatterin
zu beantworten und uns auch sogar online
zu Gesprächen zur Verfügung stehen wenn
es schwierig wird mal einen
präsenztermin zu machen ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir auch im Haushalt
für das Jahr 2023 gemeinsam wieder
einiges auf die Beine stellen werden
wenn es auch dann im Haushalt
gegenfinanziert werden muss aber ich
denke das kriegen wir hin das ist auch
dringend erforderlich im Hinblick auf
die vielen Belastungen die Landwirte
Waldbesitzer Gartenbaubetriebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger derzeit erfahren
und Herr Bürger ich will noch sagen also
das Vertrauen der Landwirte das haben
sie in der letzten Legislatur unter
schwarz geführten BMW schon längst
verloren danke
[Applaus]
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Peter Felser
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister liebe Kollegen liebe Gäste
Liebe Landwirte ich habe keine
Katzenfotos mitgebracht sondern eine
Geschichte aus dem harten bäuerlichen
Alltag vorgestern darf ich eine Winzerin
auf eine Veranstaltung das was sie sagt
ist symptomatisch für die aktuelle
Situation in der Landwirtschaft
diese junge weinbäuerin sprach davon
dass sie Ängste habe wie es denn nun
weitergehen soll man habe es
selbstverständlich seit Jahrzehnten seit
Jahrhunderten auf dem Weinberg
nachhaltig gewirtschaftet
selbstverständlich gehe man mit der
anvertrauten Natur dem eigenen Weinberg
natürlich sorgfältig um aber das was nun
an Auflagen Einschränkungen und
Bürokratie auf sie zukomme das mache ihr
Angst Angst liebe Kollegen Angst geht um
auf den bäuerlichen Betrieben dieser
emotionale Appell der Winzerin war aber
nicht irgendwo hingerichtet er hat sich
ganz klar gegen diese Politik der Ampel
gerichtet
dabei
dabei wäre Stabilität das richtige
Signal für unsere Landwirte Stabilität
und Planbarkeit stattdessen Unsicherheit
Verzweiflung Angst auf unseren Betrieben
denn wie ist denn die echte Lage die
Schere von Kosten auf der einen Seite zu
den Erträgen auf der anderen Seite gehen
immer weiter auseinander Stichworte
Gaspreise gehen durch die Decke Dünger
Inflation ab Oktober werden die
Tierhalter die steigenden Kosten durch
die tierärztegebührenordnung zu spüren
bekommen haben sie das eigentlich alles
auf dem Schirm jetzt macht die größte
düngemittelfirma in Deutschland dicht
was für eine zusätzliche Dramatik in
dieser Situation irre steigende
Betriebskosten und weniger Düngemittel
auf dem Markt aber genau das liebe
Kollegen genau das war vorhersehbar dazu
brauchte man auch keine Glaskugel wir
hatten im Mai in unserem Antrag genau
auf diese Situation hingewiesen wir
haben uns stark gemacht bei der sicher
der Düngemittel für bezahlbare
Düngemittel wir haben konkret
vorgeschlagen wie wir das für die
Landwirte sichern können nur ein paar
Auszüge sicherstellen dass die Dünger
Produktion in Deutschland gewährleistet
bleibt im Rahmen der einzelstaatlichen
Beihilfen Unterstützung bei den
düngerkosten auf nationale Ebene
sicherstellen dass es eu-nitratsmessnetz
so ausgebaut wird dass es engmaschig und
fachlich geeignet ist aber auch hier
Augen zu und weiter Schlingerkurs in die
Katastrophe
das schlimme ist diese Kostenexplosionen
diese Mangelwirtschaft das wird sich
dann wiederum in steigenden
Lebensmittelpreisen wiederfinden das
zahlen die Bürger und das liebe Kollegen
das ist das unsoziale auch in der
Agrarpolitik
Herr Minister werden sie eigentlich in
ihrem eigenen Kabinett ernst genommen es
kann doch nicht wahr sein dass unsere
Landwirte im Entlastungspaket überhaupt
nicht vorkommen 0,0 das ist der
eigentliche Skandal den wir in dieser
haushaltswoche erleben müssen
und in Brüssel Herr Minister in Brüssel
sind sie ebenfalls gnadenlos geschnitten
worden Ausnahme keinerlei Hilfe für
unsere Schweinehalter in der asp-frage
gerade in Niedersachsen haben sich da
viele Betrieben Hilfe gewünscht sie
haben
0,0 für unsere Landwirte rausgeholt mit
dieser EU werden in Deutschland noch
mehr Betriebe dicht machen das ist
leider die bittere Wahrheit lassen Sie
mich aber noch zu Forstpolitik kommen es
ist schade dass unser Wald in der
Haushaltsdebatte meistens zu kurz kommt
besprechen hier im Haushalt immerhin
über 900 Milliarden Millionen Euro
allein in diesem Jahr sollen noch 200
Millionen in die Wälder in den Waldumbau
abfließen wie soll das funktionieren
Realität die Kriterien sollten Anfang
September vorliegen jetzt haben wir 8
September wir hören das dauert noch ein
zwei Wochen zwölf Kriterien sind zu
erfüllen damit die Förderung überhaupt
ausbezahlt werden kann wer soll das ab
Ende September oder ab Oktober noch
hinbekommen das ist völlig
realitätsfremd das Personal das wir
hierzu benötigen und ich rede hier nur
von der kommissionsleistung von
Evaluation Controlling noch gar nicht zu
reden das Personal für diese
Beratungsleistung haben Sie in den
letzten Jahrzehnten systematisch
abgebaut auch sie die Kollegen von der
CDU es fehlt schlicht und einfach die
Förster in der Fläche
die Forstbetriebsgemeinschaften sollen
jetzt anfangen zu beraten über Kriterien
die sie bislang noch gar nicht hatten
schliegerkurs ins Nichts ich kann Ihnen
sagen wie es ausgeht dazu brauche ich
auch keine Kristallkugel es werden die
die weitbesitzer und die
forstgemeinschaften die Förderung
beantragen und bekommen deren Wald jetzt
schon diese Kriterien erfüllen
die kleinen Waldbesitzer die
kleinwaldbesitzer werden leer ausgehen
Ergebnis für das Klima
0,0 liebe Kollegen unsere Landwirte
haben nicht nur einen anderen Haushalt
verdient sie haben eine andere Regierung
verdient ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das
Wort Gero Clemens Hocker
verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn man mit
Menschen spricht vielleicht gerade
während der Sommermonate die aus dem
Ausland nach Deutschland kommen um hier
Urlaub zu machen vielleicht Ihre Ferien
hier verbringen wollen mit Ihnen über
Landwirtschaft spricht dann ist für mich
ganz offenkundig dass diese Menschen
über die Landwirte in ihrem Heimatland
mit sehr viel Wertschätzung sprechen
und wenn ich das Vergleiche damit wie
Diskussion über Landwirtschaft in
Deutschland sehr häufig verlaufen
sage ich Ihnen dass ich mir sehr
wünschen würde für die kommenden Monate
und Jahre dass dieses permanente
bauernbashing was in Gesellschaft und
auch in Teilen der Politik allzu häufig
unseren Landwirten
entgegenschlägt sie wären pauschal
klimaschänder Tierquäler oder
Brunnenvergifter dass das endlich einmal
aufhört meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren wir sind alle aufgerufen diesen
Menschen diesen Männern und Frauen die
nach höchsten Standards Lebensmittel in
Deutschland produzieren mit
Wertschätzung zu begegnen und nicht mit
diesem bauernbashing förderte Kollegen
und Kollegen
es passiert seit mindestens zwei
Wahlperioden in der
Landwirtschaftspolitik in Deutschland
etwas ganz ich nenne es mal eigenartiges
immer Menschen erklären sie wären gerne
bereit einen höheren Preis für
Lebensmittel zu bezahlen die nach
höchsten Standards erzeugt wurden
höchsten tierhaltungsstufen vielleicht
dem Verzicht auf chemischen
Pflanzenschutz und viele andere Dinge
mehr und Politik hat sich diese Wünsche
zu eigen gemacht die er häufig noch von
NGOs befeuert wurden und hat daraus
häufig genug nationalstaatliche
Alleingänge beschritten gerade rund in
den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten
insektenschutzpaket
nutztierhalterverordnung
düngerverordnung und viele andere
politische Entscheidungen die häufig nur
nationalstaatlich verabschiedet wurden
oder bei denen bei dem was aus Brüssel
kommen noch ein bisschen was oben drauf
gelegt wurde haben die Produktionskosten
für Lebensmittel in Deutschland
nachhaltig steigen lassen das wäre noch
nicht mal ein Problem meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wenn
tatsächlich der Verbraucher seinen
Anforderungen die er bei Umfragen
artikuliert tatsächlich auch Taten
folgen lassen würde und auch zum
höherpreisigen Lebensmittel greifen
würde genau das passiert aber nicht und
daraus ist eine Diskrepanz entstandenen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und es ist
allerhöchste Eisenbahn dass wir beginnen
zu handeln und die ländlichen Regionen
und die Bäuerinnen und Bauern mit dieser
prekären Situation nicht länger allein
lassen fertig Kollegen und Kollegen
und deswegen haben wir Freie Demokraten
uns auf den Weg gemacht wir strecken die
Hand aus in Richtung unserer
Koalitionspartner und gerne auch in
Richtung der Opposition eine
Kompensation zu beschließen für diese
Mehrbelastung die Politik und auch die
ehemaligen Bundesregierungen verursacht
haben und die eben für
landwirtschaftliche Betriebe nicht
länger zu tragen sind uns schwebt vor
eine Kompensation in Höhe von 40 Cent
pro verkauftem Kilogramm Fleisch dieses
Geld soll unmittelbar für Investitionen
in Stelle in noch mehr und noch höher
standardisierte Tierhaltung fließen und
auch die Produktionskosten und auch die
Betriebskosten abdecken meine sehr
freuen das ist richtig und gut nicht
weil wir irgendjemand krampfhaft was
Gutes tun wollen sondern weil wir der
festen Überzeugung sind meine Damen und
Herren das ist nicht ausreicht den
Menschen in den ländlichen Regionen
Wertschätzung entgegenzubringen sondern
es muss auch in Zukunft Wertschöpfungen
diesen Regionen möglich sein denn es
wäre undenkbar wenn sich all diese
Menschen auf nicht machen würden in die
Städte weil in ländlichen Regionen keine
Perspektive mehr für sie existiert hier
ist Politik gefordert und hier machen
wir einen riesengroßen Schritt auf
unsere Koalitionspartner zu verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
[Applaus]
gleichzeitig sind wir gehalten verehrte
Frau Kollegin Künast ich weiß dass sie
auf diesen Hinweis gewartet haben weil
ich ihn schon oft erwähnt habe in
unseren Gesprächen verantwortungsvoll
mit diesen Mitteln umzugehen und dazu
gehört das Landwirt die sich auf den Weg
machen zu investieren mit diesen Mitteln
von denen ich eben gesprochen habe auch
die Gewehr bekommen müssen das für die
Dauer ihrer Investition für die Dauer
der Abschreibung keine zusätzlichen
Auflagen über ihnen ausgeschüttet werden
für die Dauer von 20 Jahren müssen Sie
die Gewissheit haben im Rahmen eines
auflagenmoratoriums das nicht die
Investition die gerade getätigt wurde
morgens schon wieder per Du ist weil
zusätzliche Auflagen über ihnen
ausgeschüttet werden meine sehr
vernommen das ist unsere Bedingung dass
es unsere Bedingung und wir hoffen dass
sie da ebenso auf uns zugehen wie wir
das in einer anderen Frage ihnen
gegenüber gemacht haben und meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das ist mein
letzter Satz ich sag's ganz ausdrücklich
Politik hat auch viel mit Kompromiss zu
tun das ist keine Frage wir haben
mit diesem Vorschlag es sich leicht
gemacht wir haben uns auf den Weg
gemacht wir haben die Hand ausgestreckt
wir wollen dass die ländlichen Regionen
in unserem Land auch in fünf auch in
zehn Jahren eine Perspektive und zwar
eine verlässliche Perspektive haben
jetzt ist es an anderen von ihrem grünen
ideologischen Baum herabzusteigen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
und für die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat das
Wort Ina Latendorf
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen ich spreche hier
für all jene die in der Landwirtschaft
arbeiten für die Menschen im ländlichen
Raum wie in meinem Bundesland
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern für die Menschen
die zu Recht gesunde und bezahlbare
Lebensmittel fordern für all diese
Menschen ist der Einzelplan ein
Trauerspiel in diesen Zeiten in denen
die Menschen Angst vor weitere Inflation
haben vor ernährungs- und energiekrisen
den wir näher sind denn je hat die
Bundesregierung aus meiner Sicht keinen
belastbaren Plan entgegen der
optimistischen Rede des Ministers bildet
sich der Handlungsdruck in diesem Etat
überhaupt nicht ab die Berichte aus der
Landwirtschaft sind zum Teil dramatisch
als agrarpolitische Sprecherin der
Linksfraktion kann ich die aktuelle
Politik der Bundesrepublik nicht
erklären denn Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro fürs Militär wird über
Nacht beschlossen extra Pakete werden
punktuell verabschiedet aber was ist mit
der aktiven Umgestaltung und damit der
Sicherung der Landwirtschaft und der
Nahrungsmittelproduktion im
Haushaltsplan der Ampel ist hier zu
wenig zu finden und das ist
unverantwortlich
7,175 Milliarden Euro Imitat 2023 ja
aber weniger als 2% des Gesamthaushaltes
und nach Abzug der Sozialleistungen von
über drei Milliarden Euro bleiben also
nur noch 0,7 Prozent des
Gesamthaushaltes für Transformation in
der Landwirtschaft für die Sicherung der
Ernährung für den Verbraucherschutz die
ländlichen Räume die Fischerei kennt den
Wald dessen Umbau ja so dringend
erforderlich ist und der
transformationspunkt genügt hierfür
nicht und anstatt unsere Kapazitäten in
die Rüstung zu verschwenden sollte die
Regierung lieber wirksam die 14
Millionen Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
Landes unterstützen die direkt oder
indirekt von Armut betroffen sind dazu
gehört vor allem eine vernünftige
ernährungspolitik denn die Preise für
Grundnahrungsmittel sind in den letzten
Jahren und nicht erst in diesem Jahr
dramatisch gestiegen laut Statistischem
Bundesamt in den vergangenen fünf Jahren
um 26 Prozent unglaublich und das ohne
die aktuellen Steigerungen und wer in
den Supermarkt geht kann die Preise
plötzlich
explodieren sehen förmlich und schon
lange wären wirksame Maßnahmen gegen
ernährungsspekulationen und
Preistreiberei nötig gewesen aber das
hat wer die alte noch die neue
Bundesregierung auf dem Schirm fatal
wir als LINKE mahnen seit Monaten an und
haben jüngst auch einen Antrag zur
Abschaffung der Mehrwertsteuer auf die
auf Grundnahrungsmittel vorgelegt
unterstützen Sie diese Entlastung als
Baustein der sofort ankommen würde
nötige denn je ist die Begrenzung der
Marktmacht von Lebensmittelkonzernen und
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte genauso wie
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher zu
entlasten
die großen Konzerne verdienen sich
Entschuldigung dumm und dämlich gerade
und die Produzenten werden abgespeist
und die Verbraucher und VerbraucherInnen
zahlen die Zeche und auch hier ändert
sich nichts sie überlassen alles den
profitorientierten Markt und verschärfen
die Armut damit in unserem reichen Land
die Agrarwende ist lange angekündigt und
die Absichtserklärung aber die Zahlen im
Haushalt stehen im krassen Widerspruch
zueinander einerseits wollen sie eine
gesunderhaltende nachhaltige ernährungs-
und Lebensstil fördern andererseits
zementieren Sie den Status Quo und
kürzen sogar bei den Maßnahmen zur
Förderung einer ausgewogenen Ernährung
alle die aufmerksam lesen und zuhören
müssen diese Kluft zwischen Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit eigentlich bemerken
und das eine gesunde Ernährung gerade
für die Jugend am besten über
öffentliche Angebote wie ein
kostenfreies Schulessen erreicht werden
kann besagte schon 2020 eine Studie des
wissenschaftlichen Beirates für
Ernährung für Agrarpolitik Ernährung und
gesundheitlichen Verbraucherschutz die
zentrale Empfehlung lautet eine
beitragsfreie qualitativ hochwertige
Kita und Schulverpflegung schrittweise
in ganz Deutschland zu etablieren und
auch aus meiner Sicht ist dies eine
wichtige und wirksame Maßnahme und eine
gesunde Ernährung zu erreichen und das
kann auch der Bund unterstützen in der
heutigen Krisensituation ist es
dringender denn je leider ist
Deutschland anders als zum Beispiel die
skandinavischen Länder weit davon
entfernt und wir fordern seit Jahren
hier ein Umsteuern und wir werden das
auch weiterhin tun meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren eine wichtige Aufgabe
des Ministeriums ist auch die Förderung
der ländlichen Räume da geht es um
Nachhaltigkeit Zukunftsfähigkeit
Attraktivität und Schaffung
gleichwertiger Lebensverhältnisse das
ist nach wie vor mehr Theorie als
wirklich das sehen wir in der Prignitz
genauso wie in Euskirchen und mit der
nettoabsenkung des förderinstrumentes
von der Gemeinschaftsaufgabe
Verbesserung der Agrarstrukturen
Küstenschutz von rund 41 Millionen Euro
wird das sich nicht ändern eher
umgekehrt die Schaffung gleich fällt der
Lebensverhältnisse zwischen Stadt und
Land also zwischen Hannover und Ückeritz
ist faktisch so unmöglich und mein Fazit
dieser Haushalt gibt ein verheerendes
Signal für die Menschen in unserem Land
und wird den Aufgaben nicht gerecht
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Dr anemonika spaleck
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ja heute
sprechen wir über Haushalt es geht viel
um Zahlen Budgets Planungen
Abweichungsanalysen und auch um
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchungen als
Mathematikerin habe ich da so meine
Freude dran und jede Landwirtin jede
Bäckerin jede Unternehmerin weiß wie
wichtig gute Planungen und
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchungen sind
wenn es um Investitionen um Konzepte für
die Zukunft geht eine gute Planung ist
entscheidend für jeden Erfolg und nichts
anderes verlangt die
bundeshaushaltsordnung
§ 7 Absatz 1 der bundeshaushaltsordnung
sieht vor dass bei der Aufstellung und
Ausführung des Haushaltsplanes die
Grundsätze der Wirtschaftlichkeit und
Sparsamkeit zu beachten sind und weiter
heißt es in Absatz 2 für alle
finanzwirksam Maßnahmen sind angemessene
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchungen
durchzuführen aber wenn ich mir so die
vergangenen
haushaltshaushalte Einzelplan 10 und die
Berichte des Bundesrechnungshofes dazu
angesehen habe so ist das wohl etwas was
in den vergangenen
landwirtschaftsministerien und der
Ministerin Klammer auf der cdu/csu denen
nicht so unbedingt lag
es ist doch schockierend wie
verschwenderisch mit den Steuergeldern
da umgegangen worden ist die Berichte
des Bundesrechnungshofes der letzten
Jahre sind da klar da stehen zwar Herr
scheuer und die Maut ganz oben auf der
Liste mit den höchsten Fehlplanung und
Steuerverschwendung aber Frau Klöckner
und Herr Schmidt haben da so einiges zu
beigetragen
ganz oben ist dazu nennen das
freiwillige staatliche Tierwohl
Kennzeichen das nach Jahren der
Planungen unter zwei minister:innen der
cdu/csu nie kam und eigentlich auch ja
nicht so richtig sinnvoll war was den
Handel dann so genervt hat dass er es
einfach selber gemacht hat
und die ganzen Planungen Sitzung
Entwürfe Administration Gutachten und so
weiter haben mehrere haben mehrere
Millionen Euro bis zu 50 Millionen Euro
gekostet und Steuergelder verschwindet
der Bundesrechnungshof war anders
anstandete zudem dass das BML entgegen
den Vorschriften des §7bho nie eine
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchung eine
kostennutzungsbetrachtung Vornamen das
CDU geführte BML antwortete damals es
sei davon ausgegangen dass
Entscheidungsprozesse die sich im
politischen
Handlungsbereich vollziehen nicht dem
Verwaltungshandeln im Sinne der
Verwaltungsvorschriften
zuzurechnen sein da unterlag das
CDU-geführte bmel wohl einem kleinen
Irrtum
das Bunde der Bundesrechnungshof
kritisierte damals das CDU-geführte BML
vertrete die irrige Annahme dass bei
politischen Entscheidungen keine
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchung
durchzuführen sein jeder Privatmann muss
wirtschaftlich mit seinem Geld umgehen
jeder Unternehmer jede Bäckerin jeder
Landwirtin anscheinend BML nicht
Ende 2021 hatte der Bundesrechnungshof
dann beanstandet dass das BML
Bundesmittel in dreistelliger
Millionenhöhe ausgegeben hatte ohne
vorher vollständige
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchung zu
machen vielleicht waren die Zeiten zu
gut man hatte es nicht nötig zu sparen
nun sind die Zeiten schlechter ja wir
müssen sparen aber wir haben es
versprochen und wir bringen das
verpflichtende tierhaltungskennzeichen
jetzt auf dem Weg
die Flöte sind eingeschlagen die Gelder
eingestellt und auch Haushaltsplanung
ohne vernünftige
Wirtschaftlichkeitsuntersuchung wird es
nicht mehr geben das wurde
organisatorisch und personell bereits im
bmwl aufgesetzt wir werden das weiteren
darauf hinwirken dass auch die Länder
haben zum Schluss
kontrollieren und wie ich gehört habe
wir FTP uns jetzt bei der konsentativen
Finanzierung der Umbau der Tierhaltung
unterstützen
Frau Dr spannmittler
einig herzlichen Dank
und für die cdu/csu hat das Wort
Hans-jürgen Thies
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die heutigen
Ausführungen von Herrn Bundesminister
Özdemir haben mich nicht überzeugt das
war doch sehr viel seichte Prosa ich
habe nach wie vor das Gefühl ich habe
ich habe nach wie vor das Gefühl dass
unser Agrarminister in seinem Amt dass
er mittlerweile seit Monat neun Monaten
betreibt noch gar nicht richtig
angekommen ist
meine Skepsis hat ein realen Hintergrund
Frau Kollegin kühnas die Unionsfraktion
hat in den letzten Monaten insgesamt
sechs kleine Anfragen zu verschiedenen
agrarpolitischen Themen gestellt und die
Antworten die wir da von der
Bundesregierung bekommen haben die waren
von einer gerade zu provokanten
Oberflächlichkeit gekennzeichnet
mir ist durchaus bewusst dass durch den
Angriff auf die Ukraine in den letzten
Monaten andere Schwerpunkte gesetzt
werden mussten aber selbst dort hatte
ich den Eindruck etwa bei der Aussetzung
der 4-prozentigen stilllegungspflicht
von Ackerflächen das Bundesminister
Özdemir in seinen ideologischen Fesseln
gefangen war und von der Union erst zum
Jagen getrieben werden musste
mit dieser Hinhaltetaktik und Agonie in
der Agrarpolitik der Bundesregierung
muss jetzt endlich Schluss sein ich will
das an folgenden Themen kurz beleuchten
die ökologisch wertvolle
weidetierhaltung wird in vielen Teilen
unseres Landes immer schwieriger die
Konflikte mit der
exponentiell wachsenden Bestandszahl an
Wölfen die nach allen seriösen
wissenschaftlichen Kenntnissen
mittlerweile längst ein günstigen
Erhaltungszustand erlangt haben
wird weiterhin von der Bundesregierung
nicht gelöst ich frage deshalb die
Bundesregierung wann wollen Sie endlich
anfangen das umzusetzen was die FDP
völlig zu Recht in den Koalitionsvertrag
hineinverhandelt hat nämlich die
Ermöglichung eines europarechtskonform
regionaldifferenzierten Wolf
bestandsmanagements
so und da frage ich bisher Fehlanzeige
bei der Bundesregierung
Bundesminister sie haben zu Beginn ihrer
Amtszeit behauptet die deutschen
Landwirte stünden beim Hanfanbau
Schlange sie wollten damit den
Landwirten offenbar ein neues
Geschäftsfeld erschließen und sie zu
grasbauern machen die Unionsfraktion
steht der versprochene Legalisierung von
Cannabis zu genusszwecken skeptisch
gegenüber die Freigabe berauschender
Drogen ist unseres Erachtens mit einem
verantwortungsbewussten Jugend- und
gesundheitlichen Verbraucherschutz nicht
zu vereinbaren
deutschland ist nach Europa rechtlichen
Vorgaben und nach Völker Vertragsrecht
verpflichtet regen Sie sich doch mal ab
Frau Kollegin also
Deutschland ist Volker vertragsrechtlich
verpflichtet den Drogenkonsum zu
unterbinden so und jetzt frage ich die
Bundesregierung wollen sie tatsächlich
internationales Recht brechen keine
Antwort bisher zur Frage verbindlichen
Tirol Kennzeichnung ist hier schon
einiges gesagt worden da kann ich nur
sagen ein Kopfschütteln die
borchardkommission hat Vorschläge
vorgelegt der Ball liegt auf den
Elfmeterpunkt und jetzt kommt die FDP
und macht sozusagen die
borchert-kommission zum Totengräber oder
ist der Totengräber der der
borchert-kommission ganz schlimm dass
das an der Uneinigkeit der
Finanzierungsfrage innerhalb der
ampelscheiter die Landwirte aber auch
die Verbraucher würden sich da ganz
anderes wünschen
weiteres Thema grundstücks- und
Pachtpreise auf dem landwirtschaftlichen
Bodenmarkt die haben sich nämlich in den
letzten zehn Jahren als verdoppelt für
Existenzgründer für Junglandwirte für
aufstockungswillige Betriebe ist
praktisch der landwirtschaftliche
Bodenmarkt völlig verschlossen in
einigen Regionen ist mittlerweile eine
ungesunde Verteilung von Grund und Boden
eingetragen das könnte durch Änderungen
bei den Regelungen über share Deals im
grunderwerbsteuerrecht geändert werden
wir könnten damit also auch die
landwirtschaftsfremden Investoren den
Zugriff auf Ackerflächen etwas
erschweren wir könnten des Weiteren die
doppelte Grunderwerbsteuer bei Ausübung
des Vorkaufsrechtes abschaffen auch das
wäre der Möglichkeit und im übrigen gibt
es noch weitere Regelungen zur
preismissbrauchsgrenzen im
grundstücksverkehrs und im parkrecht die
wir ändern können aber die
Bundesregierung tut dort nichts auch da
wieder völlige Fehlanzeige
die aktuelle Mangelsituation im
Energiesektor sowie im mineralödinger
Markt
haben die landwirtschaftlichen
Produktionskosten dramatisch erhöht die
zum Teil gestiegenen Erzeugerpreise
können das bei weitem nicht auffangen
deshalb halten wir als Unionsfraktion
unsere Forderung aufrecht den Zeitraum
für die Möglichkeit zur sogenannten
gewinnleitung nach Paragraph
32c-einkommensteuergesetz zu verlängern
oder komplett zu entfristen leider hat
die Bundesregierung dies bisher
abgelehnt stattdessen beabsichtigt die
Bundesregierung zum Jahreswechsel
beträchtliche Mehrbelastungen für die
Landwirtschaft ja gerade die
Steuersenkungspartei die vermeintlich
die FDP trägt steuerliche Mehrbelastung
für die Landwirtschaft mit denn Kollege
Hocker hören Sie bitte zu es soll
nämlich jetzt der Durchschnittssatz von
9,5 bei der
pauschalsatzbesteuerung von 9,5 auf 9
Prozent gesenkt werden das trifft
insbesondere die kleineren
landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe und führt
zu einer Mehrbelastung zweistelligen
Millionen Euro Bereich der hlbs hat die
Berechnungen des
Bundesfinanzministeriums als
europa-widrig entlarvt aber auch die
Bundesregierung bleibt ohne Angabe von
Gründen bei Ihrer bisherigen Position
das ist
bei jeder sachlichen Kritik und kann
also irgendwie überhaupt nicht
nachvollzogen werden meine sehr
verehrten
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Beispiele zeigen dass zum Schluss
Regierung noch viel Arbeit liegt und
bisher sehr wenig passiert ist herr
Özdemir ihre Arbeit Bilanz bisher ist
enttäuschend wir hoffen dass das besser
wird vielen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Isabel Mackensen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Minister wir haben es gehört sie
sind nicht nur Landwirtschaftsminister
ernährungsminister sondern auch unser
Forstminister die Wälder leiden und sind
durch dürrenstürme und Waldbrände stark
mitgenommen das konnten wir dieses Jahr
hautnah wieder einmal miterleben das
Frühjahr 2022 war viel zu trocken und ab
Juni ging auch schon die
sommerhitzewelle los das hat vielerorts
zu Waldbränden geführt aktuell sehen wir
die schrecklichen Bilder aus dem Harz
auch in meinem Wahlkreis hat es
beispielsweise rund um das Hambacher
Schloss gebrannt vielen Dank an alle
Einsatzkräfte die überwiegend
ehrenamtlich tätig sind sie haben
unbeschreibliches geleistet
in Deutschland sind Waldbrände nur in
sehr geringen Maßen natürlichen
Ursprungs vielmehr sind leider die
Ursachen auf fahrlässigtes Verhalten der
BürgerInnen im Wald zurückzuführen hier
gilt es Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten ein
besonderes Risiko besteht in sogenannten
Nadelholz Reinbeständen auch
Monokulturen genannt vor allem
Kiefernwälder bergen ein besonders hohes
waldbrandrisiko daher ist der Umbau
unserer Wälder zu naturnahen
Mischwäldern mit hohem Anteil
klimaresilienter Laubbäume auch
präventiver Brandschutz
wenn Wälder abbrennen gehen die vielen
Ökosystemleistungen verloren die uns der
Wald einfach so zur Verfügung stellt der
Klimaschutz der Wald ist ein eine
Kohlenstoffsenke die der
Biodiversitätsschutz das Ökosystem Wald
bietet einer Vielzahl von Pflanzen Tier
und Pilzarten ein Lebensraum die
Bereitstellung des nachwachsenden
Rohstoffs Holz die Holzwirtschaft spielt
eine wichtige Rolle im ländlichen Raum
für die regionale Wertschöpfung und als
Arbeitgeber Wasserschutz das eine
besonders große Bedeutung für unsere
Trinkwassergewinnung und Freizeit und
Erholungsort wir haben nicht nur in der
corona-pandemie einen emotional einer
emotionale Verbindung zu unserem Wald
sondern er ist schon seit Jahrhunderten
im Herzen der Menschen und wir haben
freuen uns wenn wir im Wald
unsere Freizeit genießen können und
einfach mal abschalten können ich bin
froh dass auch für den Haushalt 2023 im
Energie- und klimafond 200 Millionen
Euro für die Honorierung dieser
ökosystemleistung bereitstehen doch sie
stehen auch schon dieses Jahr bereit und
das ist ein tolles Beispiel dafür dass
es auch mal schnell gehen kann im April
20021 also in der letzten Legislatur
haben Aloys Gehrig und ich den Antrag
für ein honorierungssystem im Deutschen
Bundestag eingebracht im Oktober 2021
haben wir die fortschrittskoalition die
Honorierung im Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben im Juni 2022 haben wir
im Bundeshaushalt die Mittel
bereitgestellt im Juli hat der
Haushaltsausschuss die Eckpunkte der
Förderrichtlinie freigegeben und jetzt
mit Veröffentlichung im Bundesanzeiger
können kommunale und private
waldbesitzende die Anträge schon
einreichen ein besonderer Dank möchte
ich an dieser Stelle an die
Mitarbeitenden des bmwls noch mal
richten die in den letzten Wochen
intensiv an der Umsetzung der
Förderrichtlinie gearbeitet haben und ja
das ist ein Erfolg dass das so schnell
geklappt hat
eine weitere wichtige und gut
angenommene Unterstützung der
Forstwirtschaft kommt aus der
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Verbesserung der
Agrarstruktur und des Küstenschutzes
kurz Gag der von Bund und Ländern
finanziert wird einige Mittel sind
allerdings bis 2023 befristet eine
Weiterführung wäre aufgrund der
aktuellen Lage aber dringend notwendig
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch alles Geld
nutzt nichts wenn es dann vom Rehwild
aufgefressen wird wenn wir unsere Wälder
für den Klimawandel fit machen wollen
ist die nachhaltige Anpassung der
rehwildbestände erforderlich denn
Schutzmaßnahmen wie Zäune und
verbisshüllen kosten richtig viel Geld
bei den zäunern rechnet man etwa mit 15
Euro pro laufenden Meter da kommt man
bei einem Hektar schon auf zusätzliche
Kosten von 6.000 Euro beim
einzelbaumschutz kann man bei etwa 10
Euro pro Pflanze Entsorgungskosten noch
nicht mit eingerechnet bei einer
Neupflanzung von einem Hektar Waldfläche
mit rund 2.500 Jungen
schnell mit zusätzlichen Kosten von
25.000 Euro rechnen in diesem Falle
ziehe ich ausnahmsweise ich gebe es zu
meinen Hut vor der bayerischen
Gesetzgebung hier ist die Zielsetzung
ich zitiere einen standortgemäßen und
möglichst
naturnahen Zustand des Waldes unter
Berücksichtigung des Grundsatzes Wald
vor wild zu bewahren oder herzustellen
im bayerischen Waldgesetz
festgeschrieben
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Ulrike Schielke Ziesing
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister der Haushalt des
Landwirtschaftsministeriums hat in den
letzten Jahren bedauerlicherweise viel
zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit erfahren
spätestens in der jetzigen Krise zeigt
sich wie verheerend dieser Ansatz war
sehr geehrte Herr Minister sie haben in
ihrer Rede im Juni diesen Jahres erzählt
dass wir Veränderungen brauchen
pragmatische Lösungen oder
Planungssicherheit für Landwirte alles
Forderungen die meine Fraktionskollegen
und ich sofort unterschreiben aber
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mir die Zahlen
ihres Etats anschaue dann sehe ich davon
absolut nichts sie verwalten einfach den
Status Quo weiter und sonst nichts und
das ist in diesen Zeiten eine fatale
Politik
das zeigen uns die Zahlen das größte
Plus und überhaupt das einzig
nennenswerte plus verbucht das Kapitel
der landwirtschaftlichen Sozialpolitik
klingt gut ja ich sehe schon wie sich
die Koalition ist auf die Fahne schreibt
es ist aber ein Trugschluss denn dies
hat nichts mit ihrer Politik zu tun da
werden nämlich die meisten automatisch
vom Gesetz vorgegebenen Zuschüsse
abgebildet andersrum gesagt da hat ihr
Ministerium gar keinen Ermessen diese
Zahlen müssen umgesetzt werden
wohlgemerkt dieses Plus kommt auch daher
dass es im letzten Jahr in gewaltiges
minus gab dort wo sie innerhalb dieses
Kapitels tatsächlich einen
Handlungsspielraum haben etwa bei der
Bezuschussung der landwirtschaftlichen
Unfallkasse haben sie sich wieder einmal
für weniger Ausgaben entschieden
entgegen der ausdrücklichen und jetzt
schon so oft wiederholten Forderungen
seitens der Landwirte der Unfallkasse
selbst und seitens unserer Fraktion
lieber binden Sie den Landwirten noch
einen zusätzlichen Klotz ans Bein in
diesen Zeiten einen Unding
wenn man dann in ihrem Haushaltsentwurf
weiterblättert stellt man fest es wird
nach dem Prinzip linke Tasche rechte
Tasche gearbeitet viele Titel werden
einfach herumgeparkt gekürzt wie
beispielsweise beim sonderrahmenplanen
Förderung der landlichen Entwicklung 30
Millionen Weg diese 30 Millionen landen
dann beim Insektenschutz wer glaubt dass
damit irgendwelche extra
naturschutzprogramme laufen nein das
gerode Mehrausgaben wird dafür
eingesetzt um die Extrakosten die eben
durch die Vorgaben dieses
Insektenschutzes entstehen bei den
Bauern abzumildern die Extrakosten die
sie den Bauern selbst auferlegen finde
den Fehler oder ein weiteres Beispiel
die berühmten Ausgaben bei der
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Verbesserung der
Agrarstruktur und des Küstenschutzes wir
werden aus dem pauschalen Titel 150
Millionen Euro abgezogen um sie dann im
Rahmen des Garten mit einem neuen Namen
Tierwohl Umbau um zu edikettieren wieder
einmal linke Tasche rechte Tasche
was genau jetzt diese extra Benennung
bedeutet man kann es nur Orakel mir
scheint als ob man überall wo öko oder
Tierwohl davor steht einfach mal ein
bisschen die Gelder umgeschichtet hat um
ein wenig Greenwashing zu betreiben
Greenwashing was in der grünen Doktrin
gut klingt aber für die Landwirte fatal
ist das beste Beispiel dafür liefern die
sogenannten Hilfen für die Landwirte da
werden unnötigerweise die Hilfen an die
sogenannte greening-prämie geknüpft da
ist die deutsche Regierung mal wieder
päpstlicher als der Papst in Brüssel es
kann aber auch daran liegen dass Ihre
Prioritäten etwas anders gesetzt werden
als bei dem Rest der Bevölkerung ich
meine damit ihre Aussage herr Özdemir
man darf es gemeint war der Hunger nicht
als Argument missbrauchen um Abstriche
bei die Biodiversität und Klimaschutz zu
machen Zitat ändern Herr Minister wer
allen Ernstes Klimaschutz vor die
Vermeidung von Hunger stellt setzt seine
Prioritäten falsch
so was ist angesichts der letzten der
jetzigen Lage einfach verheerend von der
Flächenstilllegung dem Fruchtwechsel und
im ewigen Zaudern drumherum will ich gar
nicht erst anfangen und was dieser
einmalige Ausnahme mit zig aber für die
Planungssicherheit der Landwirte
bedeutet auch nicht dass die
Bundesregierung völlig abgekappelt von
der Realität ist liefert ja auch vor
einigen Tagen ihre Antwort auf eine
Anfrage aus der afd-fraktion nachgefragt
nach den Konsequenzen dass immer mehr
Düngemittelhersteller ihre Werke
schließen kamen noch ernsthaft die
Antwort ich zitiere die konkreten Folgen
für die düngemittelversorgung der
heimischen Landwirtschaft lassen sich
noch nicht erkennen man werde die
Entwicklung der Gaspreise und die
diesbezüglichen Reaktion der
Düngemittelindustrie weiter genau
beobachten Zitat Ende meine Damen und
Herren das ist für die Landwirte doch
blanker Hohn auf der anderen Seite
planen sie fast 25 Millionen Euro extra
Ausgaben im Landwirtschaftsministerium
und den nachgeordneten Behörden das
alles nachdem sie jetzt im Juni diesen
Jahres mit dem Haushalt für 22 ganze 80
Millionen Euro extra für diesen
Verwaltungsapparat bereitgestellt haben
das heißt in dem guten halben Jahr
seitdem sie das Ministerium übernommen
haben wachsen allein die Ausgaben ihres
Ministeriums und der nachgeordneten
Behörden um satte 100 Millionen Euro das
sind ihre eigentlichen Prioritäten
lieber Ampel wacht einfach endlich auf
wir stecken in einer Krise und wir
können uns nicht erlauben zu träumen
oder in den Status Quo zu verwalten
draußen in der realen Welt gehen die
Preise durch die Decke und nicht nur die
Landwirte sehen keine Zukunft mehr wenn
ihr nichts getan habt Deutschland
Aufwachen dass wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen können vielen Dank
und der nächste Redner von der
FDP-Fraktion ist Frank Schaeffler
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine lieben Kollegen
und Kollegen der Einzelplan 10 ist ein
großer Haushalt innerhalb dieses
Gesamtetats mit 7,175 Milliarden Euro
größte Positionen ist die
landwirtschaftliche Sozialpolitik mit
fast vier Milliarden also 56 Prozent des
etas das Landwirtschaftsministers gehen
in die Sozialpolitik der Landwirte und
das ist auch ein gutes Zeichen denn das
wird entsprechend ausgebaut
wichtig ist auch dass wir die Institute
die Forschungsinstitute
in diesem Bereich weiter stärken und die
glaube auch das ist wichtig dass Sie
Forschung im landwirtschaftlichen
Bereich auch weiter nach vorne geht dass
wir auch in diesem Bereich weitere
Erfolge erzielen was Anbau Methoden
betrifft was das Saatgut betrifft auch
das ist eine wichtige Aufgabe die wir
hier in diesem METAR weiter fördern
wollen
der Minister hat vorhin davon gesprochen
dass es Ziel sein muss Fleisch aus
heimischer Produktion zu fördern
Fleisch ist aber nur ein Bestandteil der
Ernährung in unserem Land ein anderer
Bereich ist Gemüse und Obst
und ich habe heute mit einem
[Musik]
Garten- und Gemüsebauer in meinem
Wahlkreis gesprochen und er hat mir
erzählt
dass seiner bisherigen Gasrechnung über
80.000 Euro von seinem
Gasanbieter gekündigt wurde und der
jetzt beim ersatzversorger ein neues
Angebot bekommen hat und dieses Angebot
trägt nicht mehr 80.000 sondern beträgt
eine Million
und er hat mir gesagt das ist mehr als
er Umsatz erzielt in einem Jahr
und er sagt mir ja ich kann vielleicht
20 30 Prozent einsparen
aber gegen diese Preisentwicklung kann
ich nicht ansparen und deshalb glaube
ich muss in dieser Debatte heute auch
die Diskussion über mehr Angebote am Gas
und Strommarkt geführt werden das ist
nämlich das was die Menschen heutzutage
belastet und das sind Unternehmen
Gartenbaubetriebe
landwirtschaftliche Betriebe
ein entscheidende Rolle spielen
der Kollegin Connemann
lieber Herr Kollege Scheffler vielen
Dank auch für ihre Worte zu
Gartenbaubetrieben ich habe in meinem
Wahlkreis ein clusteranggartenbau
Betrieben dort wird wahrscheinlich jede
zweite Salatgurke erzeugt die derzeit
noch in Deutschland gegessen wird und
ich war auch bei diesen Betrieben und
für diese Betriebe ist nicht nur die
Explosion an Gaspreisen die sie
zutreffend geschildert haben und vielen
Dank dafür dass sie deutlich gemacht
haben welche existenzielle
Beeinträchtigung schon durch diese
Preisexplosion entstehen aber diese
Betriebe sagten für uns ist der letzte
Tropfen der das fast zum Überlaufen
bringt die gasumlage für einen mittleren
Betrieb bei mir mit wenigen Mitarbeitern
kostet diese gasumlage plus 300.000 Euro
pro Jahr und deshalb frage ich Sie wenn
Sie es ernst meinen mit einer Entlastung
weshalb haben sie heute auch als FDP
unseren Antrag auf Aussetzung der
gasumlage abgelehnt
naja
wissen sie das Problem ist ja doch ein
bisschen komplexer und der
Wirtschaftsminister zu dem ich nachher
noch komme der ist ja dabei diese Fragen
auch neu auszujustieren und das halte
ich auch für zwingend erforderlich aber
es ist ja nicht nur eine Frage des
Gaspreises sondern ist natürlich auch
eine Frage des Strompreises und der
Strompreis beeinflusst letztendlich
mittelbar auch den Gaspreis und deshalb
sage ich müssen wir eben auch müssen wir
eben auch über die den Fortbestand der
Kernkraftwerke in diesem Land neu
nachdenken dass es zwingend notwendig
wir brauchen mehr auf der Angebotsseite
das ist nämlich das entscheidende das
führt letztendlich dazu dass die
Menschen entlastet werden
allein die Umverteiler allein die
Umverteilung von Lasten reicht da eben
aus meiner Sicht eben alleine nicht aus
und deshalb ist es notwendig dass wir in
der Energie
umsteigen und das gehört eben leider
auch zur Wahrheit dazu da tragen sie
natürlich als Union auch maßgeblich
Verantwortung für diese Entwicklung die
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas muss
sich letztendlich unter anderem auch die
Union ans Revers heften
das heißt wir müssen das Angebot erhöhen
und das heißt letztendlich wir müssen am
Ende
Kernkraftwerke wieder ans Netz nehmen
und ich bin mir auch sehr sicher das
wird in Deutschland passieren der Druck
ist so groß dass wir letztendlich hier
zusätzliche Maßnahmen brauchen
positiv
will ich betonen dass der Minister
einen wichtigen Schritt getan hat in
diesem Sommer ich kann mich noch an die
Haushaltsdebatten beim letzten Maler
erinnern als es um die vier prozentige
Flächenstilllegung ging damals hat der
Minister sich noch vehement dagegen
gewehrt ich glaube sein guter Schritt
dass hier endlich vorangegangen wird und
dass wir hier auch zusätzliche
Produktionskapazitäten in Deutschland
erhalten wichtig ist aus meiner Sicht
dass man das aber nicht nur für ein Jahr
macht sondern wir leben in einer Zeit wo
er wo die Ernährungssituation in der
weltrekär bleibt und deshalb muss sie
Produktionskapazität auch
aufrechterhalten bleiben das heißt es
muss über das kommende Jahr hinaus auch
die Flächenstilllegung ausgesetzt werden
und dann glaube ich brauchen wir
eine Landwirtschaft die letztendlich
unternehmerische Perspektiven auch
ermöglicht bei Kollege Hocker hat das
vorhin gesagt wir brauchen ein
Moratorium an Maßnahmen damit auch
landwirtschaftliche Betriebe auch
tatsächlich verlässlich sein können und
da will ich
betonen dass am Ende es nicht immer neue
Regelungen sein dürfen die Landwirte
beeinträchtigen sondern da will ich es
mit dem Wirtschaftsminister beenden
Ludwig Erhard
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wir leiden nicht an zu wenig Staat
sondern wir leiden an zu viel Staat
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Christina Johanna
Schröder
ja
lassen sich Zeit wir fangen erst an wenn
Sie hier am Rednerpult sind
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen liebe Gäste als ich muss mal
ein bisschen aufräumen
Herr Scheffler ich lade sie super gerne
nach Niedersachsen ein wir sind das Land
was Wind und Sonnenenergie hat wir sind
übrigens das Land mit den geringsten
Strompreisen und eben mit der besten
Netzstabilität also kommen Sie zu uns
Herr Bilger und geschätzte Kollegin
Connemann sie haben ja vollkommen recht
mit den energieintensiven Unternehmen
die gibt es eben auch in Mittelstand die
gibt es in der Landwirtschaft das sind
die gemüseproduzierenden das sind
Bäckereien und genau deswegen schafft
unser Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
Abhilfe nicht nur Unternehmen die im
internationalen Wettbewerb stehen
sondern eben auch Mittelständler die
mehr als drei Prozent für Energie
ausgeben werden berücksichtigt
und das aller aller wichtigste
eigentlich gehe ich auf die Kollegen da
an blauen nicht ein aber was sie an
Lügen und postfaktischen Informationen
über James die mir verbreiten seine
Frechheit
die FAZ musste das Zitat was sie
vorgebracht haben korrigieren das
passiert sicherlich auch mal
JournalistInnen aber sie schlachten das
weiter aus einfach nur um die
Gesellschaft zu spalten
Herr Thies ich bin total begeistert
bitte reden sie mal mit ihren Wohn- und
baupolitikern ich glaube dann kommen wir
mit der Opposition auch zu einer aktiven
Bodenpolitik und Frau Latendorf
also wie funktioniert eigentlich unsere
Politik wir wollen nicht nur ein Gesetz
ein fehlerstrich ein Haushaltstitel
sondern wir setzen breit an und Sie
haben zu Recht die gute Ernährung
benannt und deswegen wird das nicht nur
im Haushalt des BML findet sich das
wieder sondern
Beispiel Qualität
s aber auch für gesunde Ernährung und
das ist es eben wenn wir an die
Gemeinschaftsverpflegung rangehen dann
haben die Landwirte nun Landwirte die
eben die Tierhaltung umbauen am Ende
auch einen sicheren Absatzmarkt und
Kollege Dr Gero Hocker
ich freue mich sehr darüber das Angebot
40 Cent je Kilo Fleisch das ist ein
verdammt gutes Angebot das hätten wir
auch schon ein bisschen eher haben
können dann hätten die Landwirtinnen und
Landwirte noch mehr Planungssicherheit
gehabt insgesamt eine Milliarde 150
Millionen Euro und dem Haushalt 2024
liegen dafür bereit und lassen Sie mich
noch einen Satz zur grünen Ideologie
sagen die finden nämlich viele Bauern
total gut die wollen nämlich Qualitäts
Fleisch erzeugen die wollen mehr Geld
für bessere Artikel haben für wertige
Produkte die wollen Luft Licht und die
wollen einfach Teil der Wände sein und
Teil der Lösung für mehr Klimaschutz und
Naturschutz vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und für die CDU CSU hat das Wort Arthur
auenhammer
geschätzte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Feder Herr
Bundesminister diesen Tagen in dieser
haushaltswoche wird sehr sehr viel über
die Energieversorgung über die
Energiesicherheit in unserem Land
diskutieren mir persönlich wird viel zu
wenig über das Sicherung der Ernährung
nicht nur in unserem Land sondern auch
weltweit diskutiert da hätte ich auch
von Herrn Bundesminister mehr aussagen
heute erwartet meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren wir sind
hier in einem Parlament mit Regierung
mit Opposition und auch die Opposition
hat Rechte und es war uns ein Anliegen
nachdem Brüssel die vier prozentige
flächenstilligung ja freigegeben hat
dass wir das auch zeitnah im agrarschuss
diskutieren und wir waren von der Union
bereit und auch die anderen
Oppositionsparteien waren bereit während
der Sommerpause zusammenzukommen und
dieses Thema zu diskutieren unsere
oppositionsrechte wurden hier missachte
die Präsidentin hat diese Sondersitzung
des Agrarausschusses nicht genehmigt
obwohl andere Ausschüsse hier getagt
haben das ist eine Wertschätzung das ist
eine Wertschätzung nicht gegen die
gegen die Ernährungssicherung das ist
keine Wertschätzung unserer
Bauernfamilien und interessanterweise
interessanterweise Vergehen kein Tag wo
diese Sondersitzung nicht genehmigt
worden ist hat unser Bundesminister die
vier Prozent auch dann freigegeben aber
Herr Bundesminister ich bin selbst
Landwirt und die Landwirte wenn ich auch
draußen unterwegs bin die wollen jetzt
auch eine Antwort haben wie soll das
umgesetzt werden wir stehen vor der
herbstausaat wie sind denn die
Rahmenbedingungen muss das jetzt
backweizen sein was passiert wenn dieser
backweizen Futterweizen wird was
passiert wenn dieser Weizen verhagelt
wird all die Fragen sind noch nicht
geklärt wir brauchen hier mehr fachliche
Antworten und weniger Ideologie an
dieser Stelle meine Damen und Herren
nichts ein anderes ich muss fast sagen
damit gleichschwert hat uns aus Brüssel
erreicht
was die Vorgaben beim pflanzschutz
anbelangt eine radikale Reduzierung mit
einer sehr sehr wahren Definition welche
Gebiete denn überhaupt hier
berücksichtigt werden soll ich bin jetzt
fast etwas zuversichtlich wenn die
Staatssekretärin liegt heute erklärt hat
dass in dieser Härte es nicht kommen
sollte aber wenn es nicht in dieser
Herde kommt dann wahrscheinlich in einer
anderen Härte und deshalb werden wir
hier genau drauf achten müssen meine
Damen und Herren
es war ein schwieriger Sommer
nicht von der politischen auch von der
politischen Diskussion sondern auch von
der Trockenheit gerade bei mir in
Franken haben wir extreme Ernteausfälle
beim Silomais bis zu 80% bei Zuckerrüben
bei Kartoffeln genauso und wir brauchen
deshalb auch Antworten auf diesen
Klimawandel und diese Antworten müssen
schnell kommen die müssen auch darin
liegen dass wir auch
züchtungstechnisch weiterkommen dass wir
Pflanzen anbauen können die diese
Trockenheit besser vertragen und da
bitte ich etwas die ideologischen
Scheuklappen abzulegen
diese
diese Trockenheit hat auch Auswirkungen
hat Auswirkungen auf die
Futterversorgung unserer Tierhalter egal
ob scharf halte euch egal weiter
Tierhalter und deshalb ist es für mich
auch wichtig dass diese Betriebe also
unsere deutschen Tierhalter auch eine
Planungssicherheit in Zukunft haben wie
geht das weiter mit einem
tierhaltungskonzept wie geht es vor
allem mit der Finanzierung weiter was
wir heute von der
bernhardkommission gehört habe das macht
mich sehr nachdenklich also entweder
setzen wir diese in hervorragenden
Vorschlag von Jochen Borchert und seine
Kommission um oder wollen Sie die
Tierhaltung in Deutschland ja regelrecht
halbieren ich bin für eine Umsetzung der
Inhalte der fordertkommission
wir haben auch in den letzten Jahren
sehr sehr viel ja Kraft hineingesetzt
die Landwirtschaft zukunftsfähig zu
machen auf einen Weg zu machen dass man
in die Direktvermarktung einsteigt das
muss unsere Verbraucher für regionale
Produkte ja motiviert dass man auch ja
sicherlich in den Ökolandbau seine
Zukunft sieht leider Gottes sehen wir
derzeit eine ganz andere Perspektive
hühnermobile stehen leer weil keiner
mehr die Hühner aus dieser Haltung kauft
weil jeder Verbraucher zu dem billigsten
Lebensmittel reicht und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass diese ampelkollektion auch
eine deutliche Entlastung bringt dass
sie auch bei den Energiekosten eine
deutliche Entlastung bringen und
vielleicht sollten wir hier auch die
Vorschläge der Opposition nicht außer
Acht lassen wir dürfen diese aufgebaute
Struktur an Hofläden an regionalformaten
jetzt in dieser schwierigen Zeit nicht
zerstören
wir haben auch und der größte Volumen in
diesem Bundeshaushalt ist die
agrarsoziale Sicherung und da haben wir
auch als Gesellschaft eine Verantwortung
dass wir auch den Bauernfamilien die
diesen Strukturwandel auch miterleben
eine gewisse soziale Absicherung geben
und es wäre auch eine direkte
einkommenshilfe für die Bauernfamilien
draußen wenn man zum Beispiel die
Zuschüsse für die landwirtschaftliche
Berufsgenossenschaft nicht kürzt sondern
erhöht und das sollten sie vielleicht
auch noch Bedenken ich möchte noch einen
Satz sagen frau Präsidentin mit Ihrer
Erlaubnis das Thema Ernährung
Ernährungskompetenz kommt mir auch viel
zu kurz auch bei dieser Debatte hier wir
erleben auch derzeit dass viele
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
auf die Tafeln angewiesen sind und wir
sollten auch über die Tafeln reden wir
sollten auch darüber nachdenken wie wir
diese Tafeln unterstützen könnten zum
Beispiel mit Steuererleichterung oder
anderen Instrumenten dazu sind wir in
der Unionsfraktion bereit vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ktion hat sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr Minister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Russland Krieg hat schwere Folgen
für unser ernährungs- und
lebensmittelsystem und für unsere
Versorgung es wurde schon einiges dazu
gesagt ich könnte jetzt auch
ausschweifend über das Thema sprechen
das Auto Auernhammer gerade vorgegeben
hat und keine Sorge also ich komme genau
zu dem Thema das eben gerade er war
erwähnt worden ist denn die steigenden
Lebensmittelpreise sind sorgen für
Unsicherheit auf der einen Seite auch
für die Produzenten die durch steigende
Produktionskosten nicht wissen wie es
weitergeht auf der anderen Seite aber
natürlich vor allem für die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher die
eben nicht wissen können Sie sich noch
gesunde Lebensmittel leisten oder nicht
unser Ziel muss es sein dass
Ernährungssystem widerstandsfähig zu
halten nachhaltiger zu werden auch wegen
dem Klimawandel und dass sich die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gesünder ernähren
die SPD hat deswegen
Ziele im chorvertrag mit
hineinverhandelt zum Beispiel die
Reduktion der Lebensmittelverschwendung
die Erarbeitung und Umsetzung der
Ernährungsstrategie die Förderung
pflanzenbasierte Ernährung die Förderung
regionaler Produktion und die Förderung
gesunder und ausgewogener Ernährung in
Schulung Gemeinschaftsverpflegung
das schöne Kapitel gesundheitlicher
Verbraucherschutz und Ernährung mit dem
Titel Maßnahmen zur Förderung
ausgewogener Ernährung ist leider in den
letzten Jahren nicht ausgeschöpft worden
im Jahr 2021 wurden von dem 15,3
Millionen nur 8 Millionen ausgegeben im
laufenden Jahr 2022 sind von den 15
Millionen bis August bis Ende August nur
3,1 Millionen ausgegeben wurden und das
in einer Zeit in der 30 Prozent der
Erkrankungen
ernährungsbedingt sind und in denen fast
jedes sechste Kind bereits übergewichtig
oder
adiaphös ist es darf nicht sein dass in
dieser Situation die Mittel einfach
übrig bleiben und dazu brauchen wir
Vorschläge was mit dem Geld passieren
soll zum Beispiel auch die Unterstützung
der Tafeln die Tafeln sorgen dafür dass
eben die Lebensmittelverschwendung
reduziert wird weil gute Nahrungsmittel
an die richtigen Menschen noch kommen
sie stehen aber vor einer dramatischen
Situation es gibt weniger Spenden es
gibt mehr bedürftige und es gibt weniger
Ehrenamtliche die sich hier einbringen
wir brauchen
nicht nur eine institutionelle Förderung
die ich gerne hätte Herr Minister
sondern im der momentanen Situation vor
allem wahrscheinlich auch Projekte damit
wir hier zum dass sie hier ihren Beitrag
leisten können zum Beitrag zur
Aufklärung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
über gesunde Ernährung und nachhaltige
Ernährung denn die Tafel nehmen
gesellschaftliche Aufgaben war und dafür
brauchen wir auch brauchen sie auch eine
Förderung
ein weiterer eine weitere Möglichkeit
für das Geld wir auch die
Anschubfinanzierung für die
Modellprojekte und Modellregionen
Wettbewerb für gesunde und nachhaltige
Ernährung in Schulen und
gemeinschaftsverpflegungen ein Position
die wir im chorvertrag vereinbart haben
gerade diese Form würde positive
Beeinflussung des Ernährungsverhalten
und der Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auch
unsere Kinder und Jugendlichen bringen
und auch Ernährungsbildung bringen
wir brauchen eine Aufklärungskampagne
über Vorteile einer pflanzlichen
eiweißernährung weniger Fleisch ist
gesund und nachhaltig und genau das ist
auch ein Punkt wo man den Klimawandel
angehen muss nicht mit Gentechnik
sondern damit dass wir auch wirklich
unsere tierbesetzung reduzieren müssen
und dafür gutes und nachhaltiges Fleisch
produzieren
gerade damit mit einer
Aufklärungskampagne müssen wir versuchen
stärker diese pflanzenbasierte
Ernährungsform zu fördern
wir stehen vor einer ernährungswende
eine wir brauchen eine ernährungspolitik
die auf Gesundheit und Nachhaltigkeit
setzt und die unsere Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher viel mehr noch
unterstützt als dies in der
Vergangenheit der Fall war herzlichen
Dank
die cdu/csu-fraktion hat das Wort Josef
rief
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Minister liebe Gäste als wir vor
drei Monaten über den letzten Haushalt
für das laufende Jahr Debatten haben wir
sie gewarnt haben wir Minister das mehr
getan werden muss um die
Nahrungsmittelversorgung in der Welt zu
sichern der Ausfall der Lieferungen aus
der Ukraine war abzusehen aber
Deutschland hat aus ideologischen
Gründen kein einziges kornweizen mehr
ausgesät und erzeugt durch das Zögern
und Zaudern dieser Bundesregierung
diese Haltung können wir uns nicht
leisten Putin führt längst einen Krieg
auf allen Ebenen nicht nur militärischen
druckraine sondern gegen uns alle in der
westlichen demokratisch freiheitlich
erfassen Welt mit der gesteuerten
Unzuverlässigkeit der Energielieferungen
mit der Blockade von weizenexporten und
mit Falschinformationen im Internet und
in den sozialen Medien er versucht
unsere Demokratie zu destabilisieren das
sind eigentlich unsere Herausforderungen
die deutsche Landwirtschaft könnte
helfen gegen Putin den welthungern
Hunger zu lindern wir müssen sie nur
lassen gut Herr Minister dass Sie
unseren Forderungen nicht schon gesagt
worden gerade noch rechtzeitig
nachgekommen sind und bei der geplanten
Flächenstilllegung eingelenkt haben als
einer der letzten in der Europäischen
Union es kann doch nicht sein dass wir
bei einer weltweiten Krise fruchtbares
Ackerland brach liegen lassen wo auch
bei uns die Lebensmittelpreise kräftig
steigen harmonist
[Applaus]
haben wir nicht statt handeln sie
entschlossen und pragmatisch gegen die
Krise und nicht ideologisch gegen die
Interessen unserer Landwirte und deren
Familien und gegen die Ärmsten vor allem
in Afrika ihr Haushalt für nächstes Jahr
lässt bisher diese Entschlossenheit
vermissen im Budget ist zwar leicht
gestiegen der Finanzplan sieht
allerdings für die nächsten Jahre ein
Absenken des Agrarhaushalts vor man
fragt sich wie das mit ihren
ambitionierten Vorhaben zusammenpasst
bei der Alterssicherung für die
Landwirte mussten sie wieder aufstocken
was wir ihnen damals bereits prophezeit
hatten weiterhin weigern sie sich die
landwirtschaftliche Unfallversicherung
ist angesprochen worden wieder auf den
bisherigen Wert von 177 Millionen
anzuheben das bedeutet für die Betriebe
eine Beitragserhöhung von 18 Prozent
Wertschätzung für die Bauern so nicht
was ist nun
was ist nun mit der Förderung von
Tierwohl Stellen schon gesagt worden sie
wollen das im kommenden Jahr mit gerade
mal 150 Millionen Euro finanzieren und
das ganze ohne einen Euro mehr im
Haushalt das Geld soll einfach aus der
GAK genommen werden woher genau ist
unklar sagen Sie uns doch wo dann
gekürzt wird bei der integrierten
landwirtschaftlichen Entwicklung bei der
Verbesserung von Vermarktungsstrukturen
oder soll gekürzt werden bei den
benachteiligten Gebieten oder beim
Küstenschutz oder bei welchen
Förderbereichen sonst
würden sie es anschneiden gäbe es
zusätzliches Geld für den stallumbau in
angemessener Höhe ein einziger moderner
stahlplatz für ein Schwein kostet heute
mehr als 2000 Euro im übrigen ich glaube
das darf man ja auch mal sagen die
Schweinehaltung ist innerhalb eines
einzigen Jahres um 10% eingebrochen das
müsste in ihrem Sinne sein beinahe in
jeder Rede haben Minister heute mal
möchte ich anmerken wohltuend nicht
sprechen sie ja von der Reduzierung der
Nutztiere interessant dabei ist nie von
der Reduzierung der 35 Millionen
Haustiere ich kann nur spekulieren warum
ich kann Ihnen sagen wie Sie Geld sparen
Sie warten einfach ab bis mehr Betriebe
aufgegeben haben und dann ein
verpflichtendes Tierwohl Label
Finanzierung
Fehlanzeige sie haben gesagt sie machen
das jetzt ich bin gespannt ob ihr in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen 4 Milliarden Euro
zusätzlich bekommen die wir mindestens
bräuchten um das hinzubekommen oder
sollen die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher bei der aktuellen
Preisentwicklung eine Abgabe zahlen die
Finanzierung ist die entscheidende Frage
ich habe die Sorge dass sie die Bauern
in Deutschland zu einem Label
verpflichten und im Supermarkt billiges
Importfleisch der markraner wird
insgesamt
insgesamt hat der Haushalt viele
Baustellen an einigen Punkten wird
reduziert so bei Forschung und
Innovation und indirekt bei der
ländlichen Entwicklung bei den
nachwachsenden Rohstoffe wurde wieder
leicht erhöht wie wir es bereits für
dieses Jahr gefordert hatten beim grünen
Prestige Ökolandbau bleibt nachhaltige
Landwirtschaft ausgeklammert aber es
gibt mehr Geld ich will jetzt nicht
alles aufzählen wir werden in den
Haushaltsberatungen bessere Vorschläge
machen von der Union wir sind immer
bereit in schwierigen Zeiten sie bei
notwendigen Maßnahmen zu unterstützen
aber niemals in dieser Form gegen die
Bauern und gegen den ländlichen Raum
herzlichen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Luise Licina Bode
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr erehrte Damen und Herren vor ich
will das gern voranstellen ich bin froh
dass jetzt die haltungskennzeichnung
kommt und Herr Hocker ich bin auch froh
dass wir uns da jetzt auch mit der mit
der Finanzierung im Klaren sind und ich
Teil ihre Bedenken da gar nicht ich
glaube das wird ein Erfolg werden im
Handel diese Kennzeichnung und die Ware
wird nicht in den Regalen liegen bleiben
bisher war sie einfach nicht drin wie
soll man sie dann kaufen
[Applaus]
ab aber ich möchte heute als 16 Rednerin
hier auch am Ende quasi zu dieser späten
Stunde mal
meine also meine Funktion als
Tierschutzbeauftragte der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion auch dazu nutzen
noch mal hier ihre Aufmerksamkeit auf
den Tierschutz zu richten wir haben uns
den Tierschutz vor 20 Jahren ins
Grundgesetz geschrieben nach 20 AGG
liegt also die Verantwortung dafür bei
diesem Parlament und bei Ihnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und Sie sollten
dieses oder wir sollten den Tierschutz
mal als Pflichtaufgabe betrachten und
nicht als sogenannte freiwillige Aufgabe
wie den Kommunen die irgendwie einfach
nur mal so mitläuft wenn ich die letzten
16 Jahre
tierschutzpolitik mal ausblende und ich
bewundere auch ihr Selbstbewusstsein mit
dem Sie hier so unterwegs sind von der
CDU und CSU ich höre hier so Sachen wie
Totalausfall und oberflächlich und so
und das müssen wir uns jetzt hier noch
zwölf Monaten anhören ich weiß gar nicht
was ich danach 16 Jahren zu ihnen sagen
soll also da würde ich doch auch mal ein
bisschen um die da würde ich mal um die
notwendige Demut in der Sache auch
bitten also nee man muss immer mal auf
die Bälle flach halten wie wir so schön
sagen dass dazu aber ich möchte heute
eigentlich noch ein ganz anderen Punkt
schärfen ich kann nachvollziehen das
sind Haushalt 2023 für den Tierschutz
jetzt kein großer Posten vorhanden ist
und das kann ich auch gut nachvollziehen
aber die Tierheime in Deutschland für
die muss ich heute Abend einfach mal
eine Lanze zu dieser Stunde brechen ich
möchte sie sehr geehrte Haushälterinnen
und auch Sie Herr Minister auffordern
dass wir da in den nächsten Wochen
vielleicht noch mal nachsteuern und
darüber sprechen es geht bei den
Tierheimen auch am Ende nicht um
Milliarden wir haben im Haushalt 22 ja
die fünf Millionen für die Tierheime
eingestellt und die Förderrichtlinie ist
ja auf dem Weg
aber aus Sicht des Tierschutzbundes
reicht das eben nicht also die haben
schon vor der Sommerpause auf 10
Millionen gefordert und ich meine wir
sollten diese Differenz nun im Haushalt
2023 auch aufstocken unsere Tierheime
sind bundesweit in großer Not zum einen
beklagen sie überfüllte Tierheime und
steigende Kosten wegen der zahlreiche
aus der Ukraine mitgebrachten Heimtiere
aber auch wegen der in der Pandemie oft
im Homeoffice angeschafften Haustiere
die nun mehr einfach in den Tierheim
wieder abgegeben werden aktuell kommen
jetzt aber noch hinzu und das ist die
Veränderung die sich in den letzten
Monaten eben getan hat wie auch in allen
anderen Bereichen dass die Tierheime zu
kämpfen haben mit Kosten für
Futtermittel Energie Medizin und
Personal und die finanziellen
Belastungen wachsen den jetzt gerade
einfach über den Kopf und ich bekomme da
sehr viele schreiben weiterhin und
Hilferufe aus von den Tierheimen und ich
meine wir können da jetzt zusammen auch
einfach nicht mehr wegschauen wir müssen
da auf jeden Fall noch mal nachsteuern
und wenn Sie das wenn Sie das Thema
Tierschutz und wird der Respekt vor den
Tieren da vielleicht nicht für überzeugt
sollte sie doch überzeugen dass wir ganz
viele Ehrenamtler bundesweit in den
Tierheim haben die wenn sie dann noch
mal auch vielleicht ihre Aufmerksamkeit
noch mal nach hier vorne richten würden
dann macht das einfach auch mehr Spaß
hier und das wäre ganz schön
[Applaus]
ja das ist interessant weil die vielen
ehrenamtleren und Ehrenamtler die da
draußen in den Tierheimen schuften ohne
irgendeine Vergütung zu erwarten die
erwarten aber auch jetzt dass die
finanzielle Unterstützung erhalten und
da ist es auch ihre Aufgabe damals
zuzuhören und nicht so zu tun als ob es
das alles nicht gäbe weil sonst würde
das nämlich auch nicht funktionieren
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss Frau
kollegia ich komme zum Schluss es gibt
viele
weitere tierschutzprojekte die wir uns
in Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben
ist ja so dass deine letzten 16 Jahren
nichts passiert ist es quasi nicht
geregelt kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss da
nichts geregelt ist packen wir das jetzt
an vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
treffe sie alle munter und wach und noch
voll in der Debatte und letzte Rednerin
für diesen Einzelplan ist jetzt Dr
Daniela de Ritter für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Herr Minister liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir sind gezwungen den
Bundeshaushalt 2023 im Schatten des
ukrainekrieges zu beraten die Folgen
spüren wir nicht nur bei den
Energiepreisen sondern auch an der
Supermarktkasse laut
Verbraucherpreisindex des Statistischen
Bundesamtes sind die
Nahrungsmittelpreise im Juli im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr um rund 15 Prozent
gestiegen auch die Landwirtinnen und
Landwirte leiden unter der Explosion der
Betriebskosten etwa für Energie
Tierfutter oder Düngemittel weil die
internationalen Lieferketten
unterbrochen worden und mehr noch ja
Kollege rief Putins Kalkül ist es Hunger
als Waffe einzusetzen um die Solidarität
mit der Ukraine zu schwächen als OSZE
Sonderbeauftragte Osteuropa mit der
Zuständigkeit für die Ukraine schmerzt
mich dies besonders doch seien Sie
sicher das dritte Entlastungspaket der
Koalition über 65 Milliarden Euro ist
eine starke Antwort und wir sollten
gemeinsam dafür plädieren dass wir uns
nicht spalten lassen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
wichtig und richtig
Tatmittel für die internationalen
Maßnahmen im Einzelplan 10 für Ernährung
und Landwirtschaft erhalten bleiben
Ernährung und Landwirtschaftspolitik
muss noch viel stärker international
gedacht werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es ist ein klarer Erfolg dieser
Regierungskoalition der
zukunftskoalition das ist bei der
landwirtschaftspolitischen Sozialpolitik
deutlicher Aufwüchse gibt nämlich über
vier Milliarden Euro das betrifft
insbesondere die Alters- und
Krankenversicherung von Landwirtinnen
und Landwirten und damit wird nämlich
der demografischen Entwicklung und dem
Generationenwechsel in unseren
bäuerlichen Betrieben Rechnung getragen
der Land Wissenschaft liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen fehlen die Arbeitskräfte
und der Nachwuchs viele Aufgaben müssen
von ausländischen Saisonkräften
übernommen werden um deren
Arbeitsbedingungen wir uns weiterhin
kümmern müssen daher haben wir
durchgesetzt dass die Beratungsangebote
für Saisonarbeitskräfte bei Fragen der
Arbeitssicherheit und des
Gesundheitsschutzes ausgebaut werden gut
so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn wir
über Belastungen unserer Landwirtschaft
sprechen dann dürfen wir über die
afrikanische Schweinepest nicht
schweigen das betrifft meinen Wahlkreis
aber nicht nur diesen 90 Tage Quarantäne
müssen die schweinemester und
sauenzüchterinnen einhalten bevor die
überschweren Tiere geschlachtet werden
können das ist EU-Recht und entschieden
zu lang danke Herr Minister dass Sie
sich für eine Verkürzung eingesetzt
haben die Zeit rennt ich hoffe dass Sie
erfolgreich sein werden und dann finden
diese Landwirte nicht einmal
Schlachtbetriebe die Landwirte wissen
nicht und das ist Teil des Problems
woher das Virus stammt der
landwirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Union Albert Stegemann allerdings der
hält sich für schlauer als unsere Bauern
das asp-virus sei über infizierte
Wildschweine eingeschleppt worden so
sagte er kann es ja gerne wiederholen er
warnt deswegen sogar öffentlich vor
touristischen reisen meine Grafschaft
Bentheim und ins Emsland nach den
Landwirtschaftsbetrieben wird so auch
noch unser Tourismus stigmatisiert
lieber Albert das Schweinefleisch aus
der Risikozone will Stegemann es hat der
öffentlich erklärt auf Staatskosten und
Herr Minister ich hoffe sie lassen sich
nicht darauf ein in die Ukraine
verfrachten so lieber Albert kann man
sich einen schlanken Fuß machen
ich will lieber Herr Minister das
Gegenteil tun ich möchte Sie gerne
einladen in unseren Wahlkreis sie haben
ja eben das emsländische
Landvolk schon so ausdrücklich gelobt
sie sind dort herzlich willkommen und
eingeladen aber auch die Not zu lindern
denn die Schweinepest hat existenzielle
Folgen für viele unserer Betriebe und
sie sind herzlich eingeladen dass dort
zu diskutieren flankieren sie
unterstützen Sie unsere bäuerliche
Landwirtschaft es tut Not vielen Dank
[Applaus]
weitere Wortmeldungen zu diesem
Einzelplan liegen mir nicht vor daher
kann ich jetzt um einen zügigen
Sitzplatzwechsel bitten damit wir gleich
weitermachen können